and the four former Minneapolis police
officers charged in the death of George
Floyd are set to make their second court
appearance today
Jamie yuccas is in Minneapolis with more
on that story good morning to you Jamie
what can we expect from this hearing
today good morning to you too Gail we
know that all four former Minneapolis
police officers are expected to appear
before the court today including Derek
Chauvin Chauvin whose charges include
unintentional second degree murder is
expected to appear virtually the three
other former officers are expected to
appear in person since Floyd's death
there have been calls around the country
for police reform on Friday the
Minneapolis City Council members
unanimously voted to advance the
proposal that could replace the police
department that vote coming after police
recorded more than a hundred people shot
since the death of George Floyd
including at least seven who were killed
I spoke with city council member
Jeremiah Ellison when you're talking
about dismantling the police department
you're not saying that police officers
are just gonna go away absolutely and
certainly not right away we're trying to
provide a level of safety that we feel
like our current public safety system
doesn't currently provide so you
actually see the uptick in shootings and
in violent crime as evidence as to why
there needs to be reformed
absolutely when people lose confidence
in the public safety system in the
police violence tends to increase after
that the vote is just the first step in
a process to get it on the November
ballot
the police union opposes it and says the
potential amendment fails to answer
questions about work actually will
replace the department Anthony mucus in
Minneapolis for us thanks Jamie